make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and
after making the video on isaiah bradley
explained
which did way better than i thought it
would if i'm being honest with you guys
i thought it would be like the john
walker video where it kind of peters
along and then just
explodes one day right like i think i
made that video on like a like a tuesday
or something and then by the time
everybody got around to watching that
episode of uh of falcon and winter
soldier people started searching for
for john walker and it just blew up on
youtube right it was it was nuts i was
like
wow okay cool so like that's the name of
the game right like go back to the days
when i would make characters that people
were referencing in the movies and tv
shows everybody knows what in the
world's going on right it's the
foundation of comics explained
so the the you know look into the
comments because i do read your all's
comments you guys really wanted me to do
truth red white and black right so we're
gonna cover this we're gonna split it
into two videos because it's seven
issues long
but uh we're gonna cover this right like
today and tomorrow maybe on wednesday or
at least maybe on like thursday we'll do
the second half right because there's an
important story that comes out tomorrow
that has to do with king and black
but this basically covers the story of
isaiah bradley right how isaiah bradley
became captain america
in marvel comics now some of the stuff
that we have here is not
overly important and the fact the first
issue is not the most important thing
ever right all the first issue does is
kind of lay the groundwork for a lot of
these guys right so like isaiah bradley
and his wife faith
that they share a very close
relationship right it's one of these
things where they're kind of depicted
uh in the sense that like at this point
in time that it's rough to be a black
american in america and so in a lot of
ways it kind of goes or
points toward the notion of like the
black community in a lot of ways kind of
being
tight-knit in the sense that it's almost
one of those i wouldn't really call it
gatekeeping
but it's one of those like you know we
kind of keep to ourselves like we look
out for our own in our community that
kind of a thing right and there's
actually a reason for that because
towards the end of this video we'll talk
about something called the red summer of
1919 which if you've never heard of that
it's an actual thing and it is bananas
it's one of the craziest moments in the
history of the united states
but uh in the end like what you have is
just kind of a rotating
cast of people right just these these
various individuals the crazy thing
about this is not all of the matter but
one of the most important people that
matters here is a guy by the name of
sergeant luke evans now
sergeant luke evans is a guy who's kind
of depicted us as a
well previously a captain in the us
military but ultimately he ended up
standing
up for a fellow black soldier who was
being and by all standards of
measurement abused in the military and
so when that happened because it was
considered insubordination he was
demoted down to the
down to the rank of sergeant the crazy
thing about this is that he was facing
this moment of crisis
when he was actually looking at killing
himself right you know he didn't really
seem
you know didn't really feel like he had
much of a purpose in the military now i
can't really speak for the psychological
drive behind this i was never a member
of the military so i don't really know
how
the the proposition of being deranked in
the military from like a captain down to
a sergeant
how that impacts a person mentally i
know that there are people out there who
just kind of look at the military as
means to an end and i know there are
people out there that are like
that's their life right so i don't i
can't really speak to how this impacts
people psychologically i'm not qualified
for that so i will leave that to
somebody who's experienced life in the
military uh post your comments down
below because i'm actually really
fascinated to know how that impacts a
person if it really does at all
but the the change of heart and the idea
of like deterring himself from suicide
comes in the attack on pearl harbor in
december of 1941 and this basically
seems to kind of
provide renewed interest or renewed
vigor for luke evans which sort of sends
him forward now following that
you kind of go into this this notion of
like these guys by whatever manner and
whatever means taking these different
walks of life that ultimately lead them
to
enlisting in the military and so what
ends up happening is they're all
basically transferred to camp cathcart
in mississippi in 1942
and this is one of those instances where
what you have is effectively two
battalions or different groups right and
that's how it was back then that you had
black americans who were trained in one
group and then you had white americans
who were trained in another by the time
segregation came along
that began to change and you saw like
black americans and white americans
being you know desegregated and thrown
into a particular group where you
basically had them all being
trained in the military together which
led to a lot of issues and led to a lot
of problems in terms of how race
relations were playing out so
of course you know that's that's not
really something that you see here
because it takes place
long before that but an interesting the
conversation that goes on here
is between a guy by the name of dr
reinstein and a guy by the name of
william price and william price is
basically the guy who kind of leads this
whole this whole situation he's got his
own motivations his own schemes but
you've also got dr reinhardt now dr
reinhard is basically put here as a guy
who is looking to
recreate the super soldier serum there's
a lot more to him than that and we'll
talk about that unfortunately you don't
really see a lot of him in the
in the beginning i don't know why i said
reinhardt weinstein you don't see a
whole lot of rhinestone here in the
beginning there's a little discussion
but the long and short of it
is that he wants all the he wants 300
black american soldiers right that's
what he wants
300 black soldiers to use for what
amounts to
effectively an experiment and that's one
of the crazy things that goes on here is
that where you have this conversation
between reinstein and a guy named mr
tully but while they're basically
talking to a major they talk about
something called the black vine and the
black vine is basically this concept
that exists and even now still exists
where you do have like the grapevine
right so like the rumor mill where you
have like you know oh i heard this or i
heard that or something along those
lines but within the black community
because of black community was so
tight-knit at the time and to a degree
still is today that there's kind of the
the the black vine in the sense that
like only black individuals share rumors
with other black individuals
right like you won't believe what i
heard or something like that and they
usually you know would exclude anybody
else who was not part of the black
community now what this has to do with
the bigger picture you know become more
significant later on down the line it's
actually
a concept they intend to use for their
own ends but the important takeaway from
this
is that you basically end up having them
saying like we want to utilize this
concept of the black vine
and that even like the fuhrer himself in
germany kind of idolizes this notion of
like the black community keeping things
to themselves
and not really having any conversation
with white americans which basically
leaves
white americans completely oblivious to
what's going on within the black
community
the the gist here and the important
thing here is that because of the fact
that
the the notion of the black vine is
intriguing to reinstein and
mr tully and they're talking about the
notion of using
you know this this kind of idea in the
military it leads the major to believe
that like they want to train black
individuals as counter spies
now the thing about this is that at that
point in time in the military it you
know from what i've been able to gather
black americans were largely used not
necessarily as cannon fodder but they
were never really given like
higher ranking roles right it was never
one of those things of like we'll send
black americans in as spies or if they
did they would just kind of be like
throw away missions or something along
those lines there was a lot of
disrespect and a lot of
uh glass ceiling that was going on with
regards to like black members in the
military at that point the tuskegee
experiments are a perfect example of
that right like giving black individual
syphilis and then just seeing what
happens if it goes untreated right that
kind of a thing and so what ends up
happening is that
in camp cathcart at 2 300 hours right at
11 p.m
that everybody's kind of brought
together right all these guys are or you
know all these soldiers are basically
brought in
uh and effectively lined up and what you
end up having is tully and weinstein who
show up and they talk to the mayor
and then you have basically price like
colonel price who shows up and when
price shows up here
that it's kind of like okay uh one thing
to understand here is that one
cam cathcart doesn't exist it never
existed we made it up and two like tully
and reinstein are military intelligence
they work for me they kill the major on
the spot and then immediately line up
all these black soldiers and say okay
every like we need 300 of you guys get
in the buses
you know and the others remain behind
and so of course isaiah bradley and a
few of these other guys are among the
300 that are thrown in these
transport vehicles and then as they're
leaving all the other soldiers who are
left behind
are shot and killed right they're just
executed by these guys and so from there
what ends up happening is immediately
following that
the entire group as it was taken by uh
the major and and
tully and reinstein that a cover is
essentially issued right where they
basically send out blanket letters to
all the members of their families
military appearances and the whole nine
yards saying like they died in a bombing
right like they died the bombing gone
wrong and that's it right that's
basically all it was
but for project super soldier the
location is one classified and two
that's why these 300 guys are here
because reinstein is basically the
science head and he's here for the
purpose of essentially
giving these guys a super soldier
formula or at least a variation of it
and trying to create more captain
americas now a lot of the things as
they're depicted here are basically a
reflection of the time so for example
you have uh you have price who's saying
like okay like we need
a whole bunch of negro blood right
because as far as the ideology was back
at that point in time
there was actually a difference between
black blood and white blood that's what
people believed back then right and the
funny thing is there's people who still
believe it now right like imagine that
right you know the belief that there's a
difference between black blood and white
blood right i mean you know people
people who believe that
i don't i don't know what to say right
they're you know it's
i don't know it's it's it's i don't know
it's just uh you can't take people like
that seriously
right but like at that point in time
that's what people believed right that's
how backwards american philosophy was
and so one of the things that's kind of
kind of crazy is they actually start
talking about reinstein who believes
that there is no difference between
black and white blood because there's
not
there there really isn't but you know
it's one of those things where it's kind
of like we'll keep that under wraps
right like we'll just kind of let the
world continue believing that there's a
big difference
the important thing here and the
takeaway from this is that every
one of these soldiers right all 300 of
them were basically taken into
different observation rooms
systematically they were lined up they
were given an injection of the super
soldier serum as it had been created by
by reinstein to see what would happen in
order to see if they would actually
become
a super soldier and the experiments were
pretty gruesome right like one of the
guys for example is given five cc's of
the serum which proves to be too much it
overloads his body and he quite
literally explodes you know while all
that's going on again like all these
letters are being sent out to these
different people but when you get to
faith's wife
and and the the statement is made to her
hey like your husband has died in a
bombing she doesn't believe it she's
like i want to see the body
like i want to see the body of my
husband right like i need that kind of
closure now understand
it's not because she's skeptical of the
military it's because she simply just
wants closure right like i want to see
the body of my husband but she's
constantly told like the cast is closed
right we don't recommend that you see
the body of your husband now of course
isaiah along with a handful of other
guys are given the injection of the
super soldier serum and they become
super soldiers it basically ends up
working but when the body of isaiah
bradley is shown to his wife faith
we don't really initially see what it is
that she sees she's just totally
flabbergasted by it and so what you end
up having
is these these really only individuals
who survived right so like these seven
guys
who lived through the super soldier
process everybody else is dead right so
293 black soldiers died in the super
soldier experiments
under the the government's version i
guess the the reworked version of
project rebirth that these guys are
basically
taking on a series of missions right now
one of the things that happens is that
for one of the guys maurice his father
basically ends up killing his wife and
then killing himself right because of
the experience of losing his family
while that goes on you then have
sergeant
evans who starts talking about something
called the red summer now this is one of
the most interesting aspects of this
story
because sergeant evans is one of these
guys who is a part of this or at least
puts on the perception that he was a
part of it and he says it was basically
the war at home
right now here's the reality of the
summer of 1919 right the red summer of
1919.
uh it's it's wildly complex and it's far
more than we can cover here in this
video
but the long and short of it is that it
was basically this summer-wide massacre
of black americans across the united
states it was the single closest the
united states ever came
to a full-on race-based civil war in the
u.s and the reason why is because
you had a series of things that were
taking place for example society
across the board at the time while you
know with the exception of the most
progressive individuals
kind of had this mentality that as long
as black americans stayed in the south
and kind of quote unquote stayed in
their
place that more or less everything was
good and this came to fruition by way of
the fact that in the aftermath of world
war one
that you saw a lot of veterans who were
coming back to the united states and
then in turn you saw like what was
called the great migration which was a
whole host of black americans
basically leaving the south due to the
lack of job opportunities equal rights
things like that
and moving to the north and so in
chicago for example the population
exploded by like 148
this gave way to a huge amount of fear
among white americans the black
americans were taking job opportunities
right they were taking economic gains
different things like that and so this
anxiety boiled over into fear now
understand that was not the only reason
why it happened there were a lot of
other reasons that contributed to it as
well but all these different reasons
coalesced into the summer of 1919 when
it was just
it more or less felt like open war
against black americans to the point
that you actually saw black americans
being killed just
in streets and nobody really seemed to
do anything about it and so what you saw
was black veterans who were actually
taking up arms against white americans
and so they were literally
buying up guns they were positioning you
know people in in like sniper spots they
were fortifying neighborhoods they were
barricading cars like they were
effectively preparing themselves for war
against white americans and so you know
eventually it all you know more or less
kind of boiled down legislation was
introduced different things along those
lines but the the the red summer of 1919
was a real event it actually happened
here in the united states if you get a
chance like don't just
don't run with it based on what i said
like like check it out right like
actually read about it
it's nuts it's just a it's a crazy
moment but while this whole conversation
is going down right while this whole
conversation is happening that one of
the guys
jack begins to succumb to the effects of
the super soldier serum has a heart
attack and dies right jack just dies on
the spot and so of these seven guys
one of them is gone now and that's
actually going to be a repeating pattern
over the course of the rest of the story
that guys are just going to die
by different means right by different
situations but with that being said guys
we're going to bring this video to an
end if you guys are new here the
comments explained make sure you guys
hit the sub button to become part of the
rob core if you guys enjoy this video
make sure you drop a like i will catch
you all later
peace
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign